[Applause]
the amount of crime we report on is
never easy but recently violent
incidents involving teenagers has been
unsettling thank you for joining us at
11 I'm Brian Loftus and I'm Denise
Valdez eight news now reporter Madison
Kimbrough spoke to parents and doctors
who share what they've seen and what
they believe is the root cause she joins
us now live from Metro headquarters with
more
many believe that the evolution of
social media may be a factor in this
violence among surge among teens and
doctors that we spoke to say that these
opportunities that these teams take they
see it as a moment to go viral no matter
how much damage it may cause take a
listen you gotta just have eyes on your
kids and really talk to them and be
there and know what's going on parents
not holding back when it comes to their
kids Victor Claiborne has a
three-year-old son and while he's not a
father to a teen yet he sees what goes
on with teenagers today Levi price also
a father to two young boys and
acknowledges how the violence among our
youth seems to be Amplified Now by
social media use you see the fights on
in school like instead of people
breaking up the fight they're all
filming it and just encouraging it and
trying to post it on social media within
the last couple months there have been
several shootings and attacks involving
teenagers across the Valley from a party
bus attack where a 17 year old boy
allegedly raped a teen girl to a teen
boy shot in his neighborhood while
outside playing then there was an 18
year old who shot a campus security
monitor at Von tobel middle school
earlier this month Dr Sid Karana
psychiatrist at Nevada mental health
sharing what he has seen at his practice
in regards to teen youth we have seen an
uptick in all types of violence and it
just demonstrates a very clear skill
deficit that there is an interpersonal
problem family therapist Donna Wilburn
says since covid the demand for help has
spiked child to child violence the
fights the group fights things in
schools things outside of schools we're
getting so many teens into counseling
because of violence that many agencies
have a waiting list and while we all
wish there was a simple fix to stop
these vicious acts paying attention and
being involved is the first step I have
too many parents going what are they
stressed about they don't have anything
to be stressed about that's not
validating okay your child is stressing
and you need to understand and empathize
from their point of view not impose your
point of view
and with summer break underway doctors
hope they see a decline in stress for
Most teens which in turn could curb some
of the violence that we've been seeing
reporting live at Metro headquarters
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now